salut comment ça va comment est ce que
vous allez bien aujourd'hui j'espère que
vous allez bien aujourd'hui on est là
pour parler de ça
en tout cas ce qu elle dans cette boîte
l'arrêt c'est écrit noir sur blanc c'est
le niveau ce x 62 x 60 produits il ya
quelques mois j'avais testé le x
smartphone avec un jean brut et sur deux
axes à ce moment là et là avec le x 60
pro on arrive avec une stabilisation sur
cinq axes 1 2 3 4 5 5 axes qu'est ce que
ça veut dire ça veut dire qu'on un
smartphone qui est là pour venir faire
des photos et des vidéos
et ça ne bougera pas en tout cas c'est
la promesse qui est fait avec ce x 60
produits volant voulu tout de suite je
vous mets à m
on est parti à budapest on est parti
voir un match de foot de l'euro parce
que oui vous regardez c'est écrit ici et
partenaires de l'euro vient là vient la
voyez boyer gibaud vous voyez leur ont
envoyé leurs aux voiliers bibeau voyez
vous voyez l'euro eh bien vous avez vu
la basse vous n'avez pas vu la barbe aux
oreilles parce qu'on s'est bien marré
c'était super sympa
match très cool c'est france-portugal ya
quinze jours je crois donc ce qu'on va
faire ici on va recaler ce smartphone
lagarde est illégale au regard des sous
toutes les coutures surtout on va
regarder le design regarder l'écran dans
pareille lors du repas est de la
performance par une autonomie en parler
de l'expérience logiciel mais surtout on
va parler de la photo on va parler de la
vidéo on va regarder s'il marche bien
s'il est stabilisé ou pas et ça c'est
une super nouvelle
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
mais de suite et avant de commencer ce
que tu as laissé un joli pouces et puis
surtout dites moi vous comment vous
allez en bas en commentaire on arrête
tout on fait une pause comment est ce
que vous allez elle ce que vous allez
bien est ce que la vie est belle
est-ce que vous allez partir en vacances
est ce que vous travaillez comment ça va
on prend une petite pause on marque
convivialité c'est plus important on y
vend marteau sans ben on va faire une
juste un petit peu différemment par
rapport à ce que je fais habituellement
on va dire commencer directement par la
partie photo et vidéo lorsque je vous
conseille c'est de vous asseoir
tranquillement pop corn une petite
boisson pénal on se met à l'aise je vous
emmène avec moi à budapest
on va regarder ce qui se passe tout
simplement caméra à la main j'ai filmé
plein de choses au départ de paris
jusque là bas du matin au soir je vous
montre les images en restant un petit
condensé pour que ce soit un petit peu
court filmé avec la caméra de celle
fille on va regarder que c'est un petit
peu moins bien parce qu'on n'a pas de
stabilisation sur la caméra telle fille
mais c'est une caméra de cfi donc c'est
pas très très étonnant mais surtout ce
qui nous intéresse c'est la partie gimp
ball vous savez pas que c'est vachement
bluffant ça marche très très bien mais
deux choses qui vont bien d'autres qui
vont un peu moins bien et auprès des
petits débris
pour tester un smartphone de vivre
qu'est ce qu'on fait on prend beaucoup
de café et vous avez de la chance parce
qu'en plus j'ai un tremblement essentiel
donc je trouve naturellement ce qui veut
donc dire que déjà avec deux cafés je
vais sucrer les fraises
donc on va tester le dean ball et on va
voir et oui on va voir si le game boy
marche
donc là je suis deuxième café je n'ai
pas encore vu le premier est passé par
là je tremble ou ya deux troisièmes et
l'âme le troisième va arriver
normalement je vais être en mode un
petit peu un peu énervé et s'il dit mme
bonne marche je validerais sinon j'ai
validé vendredi saïd rien tu as fait
bien à vous les studios
si l'épisode 100 m excuse moi excuse moi
tu es vraiment un nul c'est une piste de
300 m mais pour le savoir il faut poser
au sol retourner et grâce au boom boom
s'est stabilisé tabiou l'a pas vu
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
on
là
ça
[Applaudissements]
réalisé comme je voulais dire on voit la
salvetat fhsab assabah pas mal chez moi
je tremble naturellement donc avec une
caméra telle fille forcément ça se verra
peut-être que si vous ne trouvez pas ça
ira parfaitement bien la game lula
guinebault lé bon d'ailleurs le gumball
marche super bien
j'aime beaucoup vraiment ça a coûté très
très smooth quand vous avez la lumière
la nuit s'est tout de suite un petit peu
moins de ça au niveau de la vidéo de
nuit sur l'ultra grand angle c'est pas
fait pour n'en parlons pas on peut venir
vous mais alors pour vous mettre tout de
suite à l'aise avec la configuration ici
ici vous avez trois objectifs le gros
que vous avez au milieu gars c'est ce
qu'on appellera d'autres grand-angle
avec le gumball c'est elle qui est
stabilisée et vous le voyez ces écrits
si vous avez un partenariat avec nice et
ça c'est une caméra de 48 mégapixels et
on ouvre ici aref 1.48 alors en dessous
vous en avez 2 vous avez un ultra grand
angle de 13 mégapixels
tu ouvres f 2.2 puis vous avez un
téléobjectif 1 x 2 13 mégapixels
également couvre f 2 points 41 tandis
qu'à l'avant bien vous avez une caméra
de cfi de 30 2 mégapixels tout bref 2.45
d'une façon générale sur la partie vidéo
le gumball c'est top ça marche bien la
qualité vraiment là et ça marche super
bien
l'ultra grand angle on y est moins pour
la vidéo dans 15 ou mais un peu mais
vous et qu'on perd tout de suite en
qualité donc la vidéo c'est grand temps
que ça marche bien et ça s'est très très
bien
maintenant il ya un autre paquet super
intéressant d'avoir réussi c'est toute
la partie photo
regardez à votre portrait ça c'est
intéressant parce que dans l'ensemble ça
marche quand même plutôt pas mal mais là
on a un petit bout d'oreille qui a pas
été d touré et là on perd un petit bout
de visage sur le côté alors c'est du
point de détail et kokoua jb si vous
regardez ils ont plein de modes
différents postes au niveau du mode
portrait c'est très sympa on perd aussi
un petit bout de lunettes sur le côté
une fois qu'on a omis ces petits points
de détails qui sont pas extrêmement
grave car il y aura des effets qui sont
très sympas il y en a plein vous
laisserez essayé d'ailleurs c'est ce
matin vous intéresse je vous mets le
lien en bas dans la description toute la
gestion des contre-jours avec un soleil
en pleine face ça marche vraiment bien
regarder ça le stade on voit bien les
lumières sont vraiment vraiment super
rebelle
ce qu'on m'a tout de suite il pas dans
le stade c'est que c'est saturé c'est un
peu au dessus c'est un peu sur
contrastée mais ça fonctionne ça
fonctionne vraiment bien il ya un très
bel effet notamment pour me regarder sur
des smartphones sur des écrans comme ça
c'est très très très cool on peut venir
se rapprocher un petit peu on perd un
petit peu ce côté sursaturé regarder à
voyez quand je change la suisse en grand
angle
je suis surmonter les objectifs les
remette un peu moins verte est beaucoup
plus naturelle je viens nous rapprocher
fois deux heures après je peux me
o'shea me rapprocher me rapprocher voyez
il ya un moment ça marche plus et le x
20 on peut y aller mais on évite tout
autant la caméra ou tel film est pas gg
mais bon voilà c'est pas non plus
combien attendre de ce smartphone l'à
une fois de plus le grand angle ultra
grand-angle frôle taf vraiment bien on a
particulièrement des fêtes des
formations donc ça je trouve ça aussi
vraiment bien qu'après on peut venir ou
venir voir tous les joueurs de l'équipe
de france gardait le staff qui est là
les joueurs ça c'est choc sas entre
elles s'attirent des ballons tous les
côtés aux coups durs ou donc ça c'est
plutôt sympa d'envoyer différentes
photos que je m'entoure dans cette
configuration
et là on arrive sur les photos une
galerie photos nues c'est vraiment
vraiment sympa ça marche bien
franchement j'aime beaucoup la faute
nuit regardez le stade super beau très
bien éclairé on arrive après dans un
joli petit bar du côté de budapest
une fois de plus c'est vraiment bien on
voit bien le ciel on voit bien les
feuilles on a bien le détail on a les
lumières en allégeant l'ultra grand
angle sera un peu moins bon fauteuil
nuit mais c'est normal et on va le voir
un petit peu plus loin également et la
caméra telle fille aux poteaux nuit on
vient à l'oublier même avec jb beaucoup
j'y vais une fois de plus c'est pas ouf
et le mode nuit de façon globale marche
vraiment bien on se rapproche un peu on
voit que ça commence un petit peu alice
et dans l'ensemble c'est quand même
plutôt pas mal l'ultra grand temps que
sera moins bon en conditions de faible
luminosité médias que c'est très normal
donc rien à dire particuliers là-dessus
dans l'ensemble les photos sont de bonne
qualité l'expérience est très bonne sur
le capteur principal avec le game boy
qui vient vraiment jouer sur le côté
stabilisation et photos nuit sont aussi
très bonne
l'ultra grand temps que sera bien en
plein jour un petit peu moins bon
lorsque vous arrivez à la nuit on peut
venir
zoomer en x 2 on va pas aller trop loin
ce que c'est pas vraiment un smartphone
qui est fait pour ça que ce soit de jour
ou de nuit
si vous avez une couleur qui est super
intéressante regarder ça c'est super
mignon c'est vraiment plein de couleurs
en fonction
eh bien je dirais de l'orientation vous
allez avoir rien coûté arc en ciel il ya
un côté sympa la couleur ici s'appelle
le bleu givré il existe également en
noir c'est lenoir minuit alors c'est
marrant parce qu'une différence de poids
le bleu givré fait deux grammes de plus
que le noir 1879 gras mais pour autant
je trouve quand même assez léger donc ça
c'est vraiment sympa il est tout autant
faim vous avez 7,59 d'épaisseur et en
plus de ça vous avez un petit capteur
d'empreintes digitales situé sous
l'écran garder je pose mon doigt et
déverrouille extrêmement rapidement ici
on a un grand écran et ça c'est plutôt
pas mal 6,56 poussée de l'amoled avec un
taux de rafraîchissement de sang versé
une fréquence d'échantillonnage tactile
de 241 alors qu'est ce que ça vous
apporte tous ces chiffres et bien le 120
hertz à venir vous
porté en fluidité et ça vous allez le
voir vraiment lorsque vous allez venir
jouer à des jeux vous retrouver ici dans
un fichage et luminosité
vous avez si dans taux d'actualisation
par défaut il est en automatique vous
pouvez venir me sens en vacances mais je
le conseille pas parce que ça va venir
consommer de la batterie ça servirait à
rien vous rester comme ça ça marche
autre petit détail au niveau de l'écran
qu'il faut savoir et qui est très
intéressant c'est que vous avez un truc
qui s'appelle couleurs de l'écran vous
venez dessus par défaut il est ici dans
standard dans ce tangage concerne manque
un petit peu de peps et est un petit peu
de saturation je vais le mettre en
luminaires et une petite différence à
haut niveau de la saturation je sais pas
si vous allez bien vous en rendre compte
avec la colorimétrie de la vidéo mais
c'est pas mal on peut bien réchauffé
très très légèrement mende et là il est
très froid là il est très chaud vous
venez vraiment moduler les réchauffer
comme vous voulez un petit peu voilà ça
ça m'irait bien
ces petites modifications à faire mais
sinon dans l'ensemble c'est quand même
plutôt bien et si vous êtes sur du full
hd + 2 876 par 1080 pixels avec un écran
qui est certifié hdr 10 plus côté audio
alors qu'est ce que ça vient raconter
ici et bien c'est pas forcément le point
fort de smartphones premier point vous
avez un haut parleur mono situe juste
juste un seul haut-parleur
alors me direz vous c'est pas anormal le
smartphone gouttes 799 euros et à 799
euros le fait d'abord un haut parleur
mono ça me convient ça me dérange pas
nécessairement par contre ce que je
trouve un petit peu moins bon c'est le
speck qui va être vraiment basé dans le
médium on est sur un parieur de
smartphones donc c'est normal qu'on soit
vraiment dans le médium mais ici on est
médium médias lors plus on monte plus on
va être médium bon c'est pas le plus
dingue aux côtés positifs vous prenez un
casque sans fil vous le connecter grâce
au bluetooth 5.1 et bien ce moment là ça
ira très bien donc ça c'est un poids qui
vraiment bien et autre point qu
intéressant vous avez inclus ici à
l'intérieur de la boîte en adaptateurs
pour venir brancher un casque une prise
jack donc si vous avez un casque une
prise jack et bien vous pouvez c'est
parce que je vais préférer parce que
c'est toujours les petits fils qui
pendouillent mais si vous voulez vous
pouvez
par contre ce qui est assez intéressant
ça qu'il est certifié ailleret genou
alors iyaz audio au casque paille résout
comme ça mais qu'est ce qu'il raconte ce
smartphone au niveau de la performance
il ya ça c'est intéressant parce qu'ici
vous êtes sur un smartphone haut de
gamme mais on n'a pas le processeur le
plus haut de gamme de l'année 2000 28
ans le plus haut de gamme c'est le sens
dragonne 888 de qualcomm ici vous avez
le modèle juste en dessous c'est le
stand ragots 870 heures pour vous la
faire très très court terme au coaching
c'est un peu habitable ce processeur se
situe entre le processeur le plus haut
de gamme de l'année 2020 qui était à sa
dragonne 1865 et le plus haut du gap des
années 2000
un sabre à 88 juste au milieu vous avez
le 870 et c'est celui que vous avez si à
l'intérieur il ira très bien par faire
tourner votre smartphone sans aucun
problème vient de la performance
vous avez en plus douzy gadrat mais
grâce à une petite manipulation logiciel
vous pouvez utiliser du de la rom du
stockage pour l'utiliser pour
transformer en ram donc on vient gratter
3 giga de ram d'eau qu'on peut monter au
maximum si on a besoin pour avoir encore
plus de fluidité jusqu'à 15 liga drame
déjà comme ça 12 g croyez moi que ça
fait là faire et vous avez ici 256 cas
de stockage en lui ai fait trois points
en nonne extensible donc ce smartphone
il est vraiment performant pour trouver
tout ce que vous voulez cette
performance ça va servir également pour
le calcul au terme de photos et de
vidéos
donc ici vous avez vraiment de quoi
faire le truc qui est un petit peu en
dessous c'est l'autonomie ici on a une
batterie de 4200 méliand terreur c'est
pas la plus grosse batterie et c'est pas
ici quoi par la meilleure optimisation
bien qu'on ait un très beau pour ses 100
ans en arrière
une fois de plus va dépendre de vous et
de vos usages mais si vous l'utilisez
beaucoup vous contrer une journée
facilement si vous l'utilisez molo molo
molo une journée et demie après point
positif
vous avez un chargeur rapide ici ils
appellent ça de la flash charge flash
charge c'est dur à bien ces deux-là 33
watts à leur charge rapidement donc si
vous craignez un petit peu pour
l'autonomie vous le prenez vous le
branchez vous avez vous boire un café
une séance de café de 20 minutes vous
êtes tranquille vous êtes repartis donc
tout ira bien de ce côté là ici
néanmoins pas de recharge son fils pas
de recharge inversée côte expérience
logiciel c'est quasiment de l'android
native s'appelle funtouch os et laon ce
point qui est basé sur un android
11 si vous aimez une expérience android
et bien vous allez vraiment vous y
retrouver extrêmement facilement il ya
deux trois petits trucs qui ont été
rajoutés par vivo mais globalement pas
grand chose vous avez un mode jeux à
thème clair un thème sombre le bien-être
numérique et le contrôle parental tout
ce qu'on attend aujourd'hui d'un
smartphone en 2021 et même en 2022
on peut garder au-delà de 2021 point
positif forcément vous avez de la 5g ben
oui cela dragon 870 vous avez de la 5g
donc à ces super bien et vous avez
double nanosims vous avez du wifi 6 vous
avez dû annoncer mais vous n'avez pas de
certification ip68 et comme je voulais
dit au tarif de 799 euros alors moi ce
smartphone je trouve vraiment
intéressant de par le gumball donc si
votre usage
c'est vraiment là la photo en mouvement
si vous bougez vous
vous voulez capturés sur l'instant que
vous voulez que ça marche vous pouvez le
faire si vous voulez faire de la vidéo
stabiliser hyper stabiliser vous avez
quelque chose qui marche bien et là
malgré tout quand quelques petites
faiblesses que je vous ai énuméré juste
avant mais dans l'ensemble ce smartphone
que je trouve assez intéressant est ce
que ça pourrait vous intéresser un
smartphone avec guy mollet ce que vous
en avez lusage si vous recherchez de la
stabilisation c'est très intéressant si
c'est pas forcément fait pour vous la
réalisation c'est pas celui qu'il vous
faudra marquer moi tout ça on va aux
commentaires et puis ce niveau il ya
plein d'autres smartphones vous avez
même des smartphones moins cher dédié à
la selphy mais ça c'est une autre
histoire
voilà pour cette histoire sur le x 60
pro 2 niveaux merci vivo à vous les
studios des gros bisous prenez soin de
vous et surtout dites moi tout ce que
vous en pensez en bas en barbe a juste
en bas en commentaire